zurück aus der sehr kurzen osterpause
und als wären wir gar nicht weg gewesen
die union streitet immer noch über
seehofers der islam gehört nicht zu
deutschland plus aktuell zum millionsten
mal über familiennachzug das heißt auch
nach ostern gilt in berlin weiter das
wort gottes meine damen und herren
und mal ganz ehrlich was der seehofer
macht ja ich verstehe es ja waren hin
oder her in bayern was er macht hilft
wirklich keinem und löst kein einziges
echtes problem aber die andern aus dem
gros kabinett haben sich schön gerecht
und im horse einfach nicht erzählt dass
osterferien sind und dann sei da ganz
alleine
das hat er verdient finde ich nicht wir
haben religionsfreiheit hat der staat
doch gar nicht zu entscheiden welche
religion hierhin gehört und welche
angeblich nicht warum diskutiert
deutschland ein land in dem wir at ist
mit 36 prozent die mit abstand größte
einzelgruppe stellen ständig über
religion verletzt meine religiösen
gefühle meine damen und herren
warum das dauert theater wie immer wegen
wahlkampf in bayern also ostern ist ein
familienfest
es ist doch ein christliches fest
deswegen sollten wir an solchen tagen
auch noch mal über unsere christlich
abendländische prägung nachdenken
unsere werte sind christlich geprägt
unser kalender ist christlich geprägt
das soll auch so bleiben
wir sind ein christlich abendländisch
geprägtes land dass die christlich
abendländische idee
wir möchten gerne dass die christlich
abendländische idee bei uns bleibt kam
sie doch wo sollen wir denn hin die
blöde idee zwei anmerkungen von mir
erstens warum lässt sich der sünder das
büro von harald glööckler design
punkt 12
die ganze debatte über christlich
abendländischen wurzeln und heimat
führen wir doch ausschließlich in
abgrenzung zum islam gehört nicht dazu
wir müssen uns wehren das ist
stammesdenken und das hat folgen
bestes beispiel der völlig hysterische
oster streit um diesen schoko hasen auf
dem kassenbon von karstadt und rewe
heißt der traditions- haase die rechte
läuft direkt am ohr hier ermordeten von
der afg die unterwerfung geht weiter
osterhase heißt jetzt traditionshauses
rücksicht auf muss liebe gut inzwischen
hat sich rausgestellt der heißt stand
seit 1992 traditions- haase weil er in
den 50ern erfunden wurde
aber man wird sich da noch sinnlos
aufregen dürfen zur klarstellung der
original traditionshauses ist natürlich
der hier meine damen und herren
wobei ein teil der aufregung kann ich
sogar verstehen schließlich ist der
osterhase die zentrale figur der
christlichen mythologie
ja ja kennen sie doch aus der
passionsgeschichte das letzte hasen mal
kurz darauf wurde der osterhase von
judas verraten
für 30 märchen
und am karfreitag ist da für unsere
sünden am kreuz gestorben
drei tage später wieder auferstanden aus
einem oster 1
das ist bekannt was will seehofer
eigentlich erreichen mit seiner
islamophobie sollen am ende wirklich
alle moscheen abgerissen werden oder was
ist der plan jetzt mein ernst das ist
der plan
natürlich natürlich gibt es auch echte
probleme die man lösen könnte als
innenminister mehr härte gegen den
politischen islam oder gegen salafisten
sehr gern
leider sind allein bei der bundespolizei
aktuell 3000 stellen unbesetzt
rost setzt da doch mal an oder statt
spalten mal für integration arbeiten
ein gutes beispiel sein ja der islam hat
ein sehr problematisches frauenbild aber
wie werden denn frauen in der csu
gehandelt
[Musik]
das
die else lebte zum frauenhaus keine
einzige frau im führungsteam von
seehofers ministerium
natürlich gibt es zb antisemitismus
unter muslimen ist nicht zu tolerieren
antisemitismus bevor die muslime nach
deutschland kamen haben wir damit nie
ein problem
keine frage es gibt noch viel zu tun bei
der integration
aber das entschuldigt nicht diesen
völlig undifferenzierten islam hass
gegen seehofer und co einmal mehr
hoffähig machen ich bin doch nicht dafür
dass hier ein gefährt wird als staatsrat
habe man keinen das einstellung zu
lassen oder solche sachen halt überhaupt
ich musste klaren dass die kirche im
dorf bleibt und dass wir nie irgendeine
marschieren müssen zu weihnachten muss
ich ein kopftuch tragen oder oder mich
verschleiern nein musst du nicht
schade eigentlich ein völliges zerrbild
vom islam
bei allem berechtigten
problembewusstsein im jahr 2017 also im
letzten jahr waren nur fünf prozent der
muslime in deutschland arbeitslos mehr
als die hälfte engagiert sich in
deutschen vereinen darüber hört und
liest man nichts gar nichts stattdessen
verschwörungstheorie keine umvolkung
findet statt
ja ja deswegen gibt es jetzt diese um
volkshochschulen magister als deutscher
rein und goms komplett wo kommst
komplett ungefragt wieder raus
[Applaus]